morning to you the government has
announced military tanker drivers will
start delivering fuel to petrol stations
across the uk from monday visa
restrictions are also being relaxed to
allow up to 300 foreign tanker drivers
to work in the uk
on the temporary basis in some parts of
the country drivers are still waiting
hours for fuel more than a week after
the delays first began so from monday
almost 200 soldiers will be delivering
fuel after a week of training with
haulage firms on how to fill up tankers
and petrol pumps
last night the government announced it
would grant visas to 300 foreign tanker
drivers allowing them to work in britain
until the end of march but the
chancellor has warned that supply
shortages are set to continue we told
the daily mail there is global
disruption to supply chains in many
major industries well the defense
secretary says a number of soldiers
deployed as tanker drivers will increase
yes they'll go up beyond 200 over the
next week that the first
big amount will be really
working through this weekend deploying
in monday probably on their own more and
then by the end of the week and another
you know 60 70 will come online towards
the end of the week so you'll be over
200 by the end of the week at least
the ongoing shortages are having a huge
impact on people and businesses across
the country dan whitehead reports now on
the problems being caused by the fuel
crisis
gearing up for a weekend of excursions
london and torquay among day trip
destinations for applegate coaches in
gloucestershire they've just about got
enough fuel but the crisis means they're
out of pocket
we quoted for work you know 12 months
six six months ago you know even a week
ago at a fuel rate that we thought we
were going to get and it's gone up by
about 20 25 percent
so we're running a loss really
it's more than a week since the supply
problems started and there are still
issues these were the queues in stanmore
in london just yesterday
the petrol retailers association which
represents around 65 percent of uk
forecourts says more than a quarter of
stations are still dry it adds that 27
percent of forecourts only have one type
of fuel in stock
and they say it's independent filling
stations that are still not getting
enough deliveries
as we go into the second weekend of this
crisis it is a real mixed picture yes
you can find fuel but in many cases it's
not easy and it's continuing to have a
real impact on people's daily lives
if you find fuel without visiting
six or seven garages then you're very
lucky
for contractor lee henderson it could be
a weekend of driving around the
forecourts
drives me totally nuts because you you
try to plan your work i've got to work
tomorrow there's probably
30 miles left in my tank i live in
stroud
i've got to drive to bristol
and obviously i'm constantly driving all
the time but i'm still trying to find
work and do jobs and it's it is so
annoying any improvement in supply is
slow and fuel deliveries in some parts
of the country are still sporadic well
it's peaks and troughs one minute one
day you're you're flat out and you'll be
taking three times as much as you
normally do the next day you run out of
fuel and you're sitting there looking
silly at each other and things like
sandwiches and food it just doesn't get
sold because nobody comes in
many including the government had hoped
this issue would have eased on its own
it hasn't and this weekend there is
still pressure on the pumps
dan whitehead sky news in
gloucestershire
the prime minister says it's infuriating
that allegations of violence against
women and girls are not being taken
seriously enough by police following the
conviction of the former officer wayne
cousins for the murder of sarah everard
it's been revealed 16 people are being
investigated by the police watchdog as
part of a misconduct investigation let's
talk to milena vasilinovich and
this is strong language actually coming
from from the prime minister a strong
condemnation of the police
it's a very damning verdict on the work
of the police by this country's top
politician prime minister boris johnson
said that the police were failing women
and girls who were victims of violence
he said that while there were hundreds
of thousands of as he said wonderful
police officers up and down the country
that it's true that there is a problem
with the way that the police treated
victims of sexual violence of women and
girls now speaking to the times
newspaper the prime minister said
are the police taking these this issue
seriously enough it's infuriating i
think the public feel that they aren't
and they're not wrong he also went on to
say there is an issue about how we
handle sexual violence domestic violence
the sensitivity the diligence the time
the delay so the prime minister laid
part of the blame at the door of the
criminal justice system as well saying
that once the police had done their work
it takes a very long time for these
cases to go through the courts it's a
grueling process and he said that
something called he called victim
attrition
women women feeling tired and ground
down by this process in some cases uh
deciding not to pursue the cases any
further and he noted the falling number
of successful convictions for rapes he
said the system had to be fixed but the
prime minister did stand
and he boosted and backed the met police
commissioner christa dick even though
there had been numerous calls for her to
stand down and he said the public should
still trust the police officers he said
an
overwhelming number of them were honest
and doing a good job now the
police have a big job on their hands to
regain the trust of the public
especially after some
tone death you can say advice as to what
women should do if they have concerns
about a police officers who stop them
some of that advice said that they
should flag down a bus or call 999 or
shout to a passerby and many mps and
just women in the public i have said
that the owners shouldn't be on women
trying to find ways to keep themselves
safe but rather on the met police and
other police forces investigating
reports of misogyny among their own
ranks
okay milano thank you
a clinical trial suggests an
experimental drug for severe covid could
cut the risk of hospitalization or death
by about half it's a tablet it's called
molno pirivir it was given twice a day
to patients recently diagnosed with the
disease the drug maker merck said the
results were so good that independent
regulators asked to stop the trial early
well there were 35
577 new cases of covert in the uk in the
last 24 hours and a further
127 people have died
it takes a total number of people who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
to 136 thousand
seven hundred and eighty nine
thirty four thousand hundred 372 first
doses of a vaccine were given yesterday
34
459 second doses were given
44.9 million people are now fully
vaccinated
an auction will take place today to
decide the new owners of the supermarket
morrisons the takeover panel says
private equity firms fortress along with
clayton de billiere and rice must submit
their formal bids with the winner to be
announced on monday
two new fishers have been reported in
the volcano erupting in the canaries
scientists say they're sending more lava
into the sea eight more earthquakes have
also been reported on la
this is the scene at the moment
as you can see it's still pretty active
officials have described the volcano as
much more aggressive
[Music]
now the queen will honor so-called local
heroes when she opens the new session of
the scottish parliament this morning
she'll use the occasion to thank people
who volunteered
in their communities during lockdown
our royal correspondent rhiannon mills
reports
the queen has probably lost track of
exactly how many trees she's planted
this one on the balmoral estate part of
a push to get us all planting trees for
her platinum jubilee next year
a relaxed engagement to end her summer
break in scotland before more sensitive
official duties as against the backdrop
of renewed calls for independence she'll
open the scottish parliament
having captured that spirit that ethos
of the way people appear like things
done i think it's highly unlikely the
speech
will be anything other than a continued
commendation
to the members of the scottish
parliament that are doing a good job but
they're obviously clear
and major challenges ahead
since the elections in may the royals
have made no secret of their love of
scotland visits to the ironbrew factory
and the birthplace of poet robert burns
a tick list of appreciation for
everything quintessentially scottish
it's not unusual to see mems the royal
family spending so much time here in
scotland during the summer but there
have been suggestions that all of those
visits may have been part of an unspoken
campaign to try and counter those calls
for independence in a way the royal
family again using that soft diplomacy
to try and shore up the union
at the opening of parliament there will
be a more obvious focus celebrating
people like dave roper who've gone above
and beyond during covid he dressed as
spider-man to cheer up local children
and will now get to meet the queen
i can't wait it's literally yeah live
stream definitely i was working
throughout so it gave me a reason to get
out each lunchtime actually going to do
something um i've seen my wife and
children at home and they were really
supportive of it they absolutely love me
doing it
and it's just it's nice just knowing the
reaction of the children every day you
went out you just cheer so many people
up you stick all these things in
unity and working together all messages
the queen will no doubt support but in
carefully chosen words the palace not
wanting to again dig themselves into the
debate about the future of her united
kingdom rhiannon mills sky news in
edinburgh
now conservatives are gathering in
manchester today ahead of the annual
party conference the government is under
pressure over the supply crisis and
rising energy prices let's talk to
former conservative mp justine greening
good to see you this morning i mean look
the
the country is in crisis this weekend
it's not ideal for the start of a
conference is it
i think it is a difficult backdrop for
boris johnson and the conservatives and
there's no doubt that alongside
setting out clear plans as to how he is
going to make sure he tackles the hdb
crisis and as you say some of those
other
economic headwinds that are coming down
the track that are almost certainly
going to mean that there are real cost
of living pressures for families at the
same time though he needs to set out
this much broader strategy around
how we can move beyond the rhetoric of
leveling up
to making that a more realistic plan
that means that people actually
understand what he means but how he's
going to deliver equality of opportunity
and i think there's probably a third
thing he needs to do which is to make
sure
that he pulls a conservative party
together you have these new red wall
conservative mps but also some char
tories who i think are feeling a bit
left out of the debate around leveling
up it's been very focused on the north
the reality is
leveling up needs to be a national
mission for the prime minister and the
government and i think that's a key
message
that boris johnson needs to land this
week
is anyone going to listen to him though
in the sense that
you know we've we've had the situation
with afghanistan which which should have
been foreseen there was there were i
mean people knew what was happening in
advance we've had the situation with the
general supply crisis with empty
supermarket shelves which people knew
about or should have known about in
advance same applies to the situation
with the four courts at the moment and
yet the government seems to have been
inactive on pretty much all counts
well i think you have seen a massive
jolt to the economy because of covert
but i agree that the big risk i think
for
the government is that patience starts
to wear thin i think people all
understand
that there have been some severe
challenges that obviously post brexit
we're transitioning to a different
version of the uk economy we're not able
to reach into that wider eu talent pool
as it were
for workers in the way that we did
before
but i do think people now want to see
very clear-cut plans on how we're going
to fill and genuinely plug their skill
shortages in the long term but also in
the short term this all does tie back to
the leveling up strategy the prime
minister has talked about he now needs
to move beyond rex
move beyond the rhetoric
and really set out some comprehensive
plans on areas like education on how
business is going to be part of leveling
up on how mayors crucially
need to get more power so that at a
regional and local level they can really
develop more tailored leveling up
strategies for very different parts of
the country that all need to have a
collective push
on driving equality of opportunity
if it's difficult isn't it in this i
mean obviously the the the pandemic has
thrown a very large spanner in the works
but a lot of people say
you know we we get the words we we get
the rhetoric from from the prime
minister and and the the top ministers
of state
but we don't actually see any action
and it's why boris johnson needs to take
the leveling up
rhetoric and really make that come alive
for the public so they understand what
he means by that from my perspective
we're doing huge amounts of work with
businesses through the social mobility
pledge we've broken leveling up down
into 14 leveling up goals some of them
are education some of them are what
employers need to do to help people
connect up to opportunity more easily
some of them around other areas that
help or hinder us like the digital
divide
boris johnson now needs to take a
national architecture like the leveling
up goals and then work with mayors and
with county councils for example
to work out how in very different places
with different challenges on leveling up
he can nevertheless make progress and i
think this is what people now want to
see
everyone understands i think that kovid
has clearly been a huge challenge for
not just the uk but the world but we're
coming out of the kobe challenge now
hopefully and it's not just about
getting britain back on track it's about
fundamentally returning to those
challenges that were there before
which is that where you start in this
country your circumstances far too much
determine
your future that is not just bad for
people that is fundamentally bad for our
country more widely because it means
we're not making the best use of our
talent and we do have some big bills to
pay
after covert and we're going to have a
very tough comprehensive spending review
but the long-term solution to those
difficulties that britain now faces
is to have a smarter economy where more
people are able to play a bigger role
and that's why leveling up isn't just a
good thing to do for individuals and a
fair thing to do it's actually a much
smarter way of running our economy
because it's how we can step up one two
three gears
to be a higher skill higher productivity
higher wage economy
justine greene good to talk to you thank
you thank you
let's have a look at the weather for you
and it's going to be unsettled this
weekend there's low pressure crossing
the uk bringing heavy downpours and
awesome gails after a pretty windy night
you may have noticed there's going to be
more blustery showers in the north and
west this morning elsewhere largely dry
but there will be heavy rain in the
southwest of england in the next hour or
two the heavy rain will spread
northeastwards across england and wales
into southern scotland much of ireland
northern ireland north west scotland
will be showery with some sunny spells
in between it is going to be windy with
ghost coastal gales in places now during
the afternoon strong and gusty southerly
winds affecting and heavy rain affecting
southern and eastern parts of england
before that transfers northwards into
eastern scotland
now there's a new and unusual exhibition
launching today if you like that sort of
thing annie shakapur's latest paintings
are violent and gory the 67 year old
says he's taking a risk
this report from our arts and
entertainment
correspondent katie spencer contains
some strong language
disturbing canvases of bloodletting and
guts anish kapoor's latest work isn't
for the faint-hearted i don't see it as
gory weirdly i think it's it's it's um
opening up what we all carry within us
clearly
at one level death is here
um
but
i hope so is
beginning since winning the turner prize
in 1991 he has become one of the most
prominent contemporary british artists
who made headlines with his polarizing
olympic park commission
more often known for his sculptures but
kapoor has always painted now at modern
oxford seeing the two presented
alongside each other the artist takes
audiences to a very primal place bloody
and brutal and almost like a human
sacrifice
we must dare
and i think as artists it is our job to
dare um and to risk it it's a risk you
know people may love it or hate it what
can i do the wonderful thing about
painting is that you just do it so
do it it's all about doing it and i
paint with a stick rather than than um
with a brush
an outspoken critic of the government
and its decision to cut arts funding
right now the artist is angry
educating our children to be fodder for
the capitalist machine
how dare they how how outrageous
it's a right-wing agenda that we have to
resist with all our energy
kapoor says the art world has to find a
way to resist capitalism quoting picasso
anish says art is war
and is that what we've got here
i hope so i hope it's war
yes
so not nice little things that you are
uh
feel comfortable with i hope bloody
uncomfortable things
confrontational work from aneesh kapoor
coming at a time when he sees the art
world that's under attack katie spencer
sky news
let's have a look at the weather for you
today it's gonna be sorry
sort of
distracted by that
artwork
um it's going to be very unsettled this
weekend there's low pressure crossing
the uk bringing heavy downpours and some
gales autumn gales it's been a windy
night
you may have noticed a few further
blustery showers in the north and west
this morning elsewhere it is largely dry
but heavy rain is moving into southwest
england
over the next few hours that's going to
spread northeastwards across england
wales southern scotland today much of
ireland northern ireland and northwest
scotland is going to be showery as well
perhaps some sunny spells in between but
look at that it's not a positive picture
for the afternoon then strong and gusty
southerly winds and heavy rain affecting
southern and eastern parts of england
before that transfers northward into
eastern scotland that heavy rain and the
strong winds affecting eastern and later
northern scotland overnight elsewhere
there'll be a mix of clear spells and
showers mainly in the west
so the government has announced military
tanker drivers will start delivering
fuel across the uk the worst hit spots
we should say from monday visa
restrictions are also being further
relaxed to immediately allow up to 300
foreign tanker drivers to work in the uk
up until march of next year let's talk
to the health secretary sajid javid
who's in central london forces one
before heading up to the conference no
doubt health secretary um
is this situation under control
i think you're referring to the fuel
situation and it's it's stabilizing
there's enough fuel in the country there
always has been what we've seen in the
last few days is uh trouble in terms of
getting that fuel to the pet for four
courts i think in most parts of the
country it is certainly uh seeing signs
of stabilization but i think it's also
right as a precaution that the the
government has asked the military to
help i think that starts from monday and
i think that's the right measure to take
to make sure people have all the
confidence that they need
as a precaution i mean have you tried to
get petrol
anytime over the last week
well i personally haven't tried but my
wife and my as members of my family have
and and of course depending on where you
live it hasn't been easy there there
have been cues i've also heard again
whether it's from family and friends and
and others that the situation is
stabilizing in in most parts of the
country and the measures that have
already been taken in terms of relaxing
some of the rules around hev drivers uh
and and relaxing the competition rules
so there can be better coordination but
between the fuel companies i think these
are all helping but it is absolutely
right i think that the government thinks
about what more can be done because you
know people want the situation to go
completely back to normal as soon as
possible it's heading in the right
direction but if the military can help
them we should certainly take up that
offer of help
the problem is what what the government
never seems to accept over the last week
is that this is absolutely chaotic you
can drive around and never see a petrol
station that's open
yeah i i've i think government ministers
of the last few days have accepted the
situation
as it is but what they have done is uh
responded to that in every way that we
possibly can and and it's also
important i think for people to know uh
that there's never been an actual
shortage of fuel in the country there is
enough fuel for everyone and uh i can
understand why people so perhaps seeing
the scenes on whether it's through media
or or social media and and reacting it's
in the way that they have i think that's
a been a perfectly normal reaction but i
think it's worth reassuring people that
there is enough fuel in this country the
situation with drivers is improving and
now if the military needed to help they
will be ready to do so from monday
yeah i mean it's again saying the
military's there is a precaution i mean
you've got soldiers on uksb given 30
minutes
notice to move at the moment to head
from their barracks to to start on this
job i mean that's an urgent situation
any soldier will tell you that
well my understanding is that the the
military
won't be directly involved until monday
and the reason for that is to give some
time for for some of the extra training
that's going to be required it also
gives time to coordinate uh with the
fuel companies and with others and i
think that makes sense but i think it's
also
really important that we can actually uh
call in the military at a time uh like
this for that extra support to give that
confidence and and have this uh as a
measure that's there as a precaution
because as i say the situation is
stabilizing no one's going to pretend
it's completely uh back to normal i wish
it was but it is it's getting in that
way but i think having the military
available in this way is as a really
sensible uh
thing to to think about what about these
these foreign drivers being brought in
and obviously the move to get several
thousand in 5000 i think it was i mean
hasn't seemed to have gone down very
well with drivers
on the continent why is this move do you
think to get 300 people temporary visas
emergency visas immediately why is that
going to make a difference
of course we've got a everyone knows i
mean this is about a shortage in hgv
drivers in particular i think there's a
shortage of around 70 000 drivers in
total in the uk by the way in in europe
in mainland europe there's a shortage of
some 400 000 so this is a an
international problem not just something
uh in the uk and uh it is right that we
try to find ways to get more drivers and
if
forgive me for jumping in but if there's
if there's a if it's a
continent-wide shortage why on earth do
you think we're going to be able to
tempt them over to this country when
we've obviously kicked a lot of them out
of course there's a competition for
drivers and that's taking place
throughout europe
but it is important that we try to do
what we can and i am confident actually
that with the with the temporary visa
changes that have been announced that we
will get uh more drivers but that's not
the long-term answer to this we
obviously need more drivers trained uh
to do this and some of the measures that
have been taken in terms of how that
training is done you know how quickly uh
those uh the training process can
proceed i mean these are all the right
measures but in the short term i think
it is right to try and see if we can get
more drivers and i think that will work
why hasn't
anything been done on this sooner i mean
we we've known this was coming there was
a shortage of drivers pre-pandemic
obviously the pandemics made things
worse some argue brexit has made
things worse
um
and we've had a shortage on supermarket
shelves for some considerable time so
why wasn't action taken prior to this
well there has been a action that's been
taking place as i understand it for for
months and indeed for well over a year
but the one thing you know government uh
controls is is you know how labor
markets move exactly we all know that
this for example has been tied up with
the pandemic across the world but if you
look at the impact on europe and the and
the lockdowns that were that were had
and the different types of support for
the labor markets from the different
governments in europe it's it's had an
impact that isn't entirely always uh
predictable but you know as we've
as this problem has uh got worse in the
last few weeks and the government has
responded in the way it has with some of
the measures that we've just talked
about i'm confident that there will make
a difference and you started off again
asking about the military and i think
it's right in a situation like this that
we can call on the military for this
type of support and as i say that will
be ready uh from monday and i think that
will further help to stabilize the
situation and give more confidence and
that's the important thing
can i ask you about
women and girls and their safety in the
uk the prime minister said he's uh he
finds it infuriating
the the police's failure to tackle
violence against women
is this a police issue i mean is there a
fundamental problem with how police deal
with this i mean you were home secretary
you've dealt with the police
you know in great detail
you know i think um that we all the
police are there to protect us and what
i saw as home secretary day in day out
the police were doing an amazing new job
looking after the british people
protecting people i i saw things that
they did you're quite heroic things that
has saved lives you have countless
number of lives
across the uk but it's because of that
because they're there to protect us that
this crime this appalling crime has has
had the shock that it has you know
across the country and rightly so
because we no one would have
thought that a police officer would be
capable of this and and that is why i
think it is right that there needs to be
reform i couldn't tell you today exactly
i wish i could exactly what that reform
should be i think they should be looked
at properly and carefully and the police
do need to be part of that reform
i mean in terms of that reform we're
talking about a societal issue here
aren't we one of the papers this morning
talking about um exposure i mean
flashing as we always used to call it
being endemic
in this country now and obviously that
potentially being you know
a precursor to other offenses i mean
what do we need to do in society to
change the attitude of those people who
are
who are putting women and girls at risk
look i don't i don't think there's one
single answer to that but it's a it is a
very very fair question i i think for us
to ask ourselves as a society and you
may know you know a few months back
before i came back into government i did
a whole piece of work and research into
into child sexual abuse and exploitation
and that includes your children
obviously boys and girls uh that were
being abused by by adults and there are
many reasons for the increase in that
abuse and one of those that i identified
and there is more action being taken on
this is is the the the online nature of
your sexual material whether that's
illegal pornography or even how boys in
particular can access legal pornography
now the government's online harms uh the
bill the the work that we're proposing
there will make a difference but i mean
that's just one
thing that i think that we need to take
more action on
yeah i mean it's interesting are you
with the view that which we've heard in
in the past when it comes to these
sensitive issues i mean a lot of people
say we need to lock it away we should be
we should be banning this pornography or
banning all this sort of stuff and
putting it in a box
is is that the right approach or do we
actually need to open it up a bit more
so we at least are having
discussions we're talking about feelings
we're talking about behaviors and
intimate behaviors and what is right and
wrong and acceptable
i think actually it's it's all of that
and you know obviously illegal
pornography is already by definition
banned uh but what is happening is uh
more work uh to make sure that those uh
those those petted predators that try to
access that kind of um online activity
are prevented from doing so there is an
issue around legal pornography access by
underage
people and the government's proposals in
the online harm's white paper to to have
some kind of age related access to that
i think is a step in the right direction
but there are there are so many things
here that you know many of them in train
i think the government has taken some
excellent action on this for example the
strategy that was published here this
summer on violence against women and
girls the straightest
safer streets uh funding to having more
police officers on the street i mean all
this is about uh making everyone feel
safer and i think you know after this
terrible crime and and how the whole
nation rightly so has been impacted by
it we do need to think again and
redouble our efforts where does it leave
you as a as a
you've got
girls i i believe um
where does this leave you as a father i
mean with the idea of i mean i don't
know how old your children are but you
know
when they're when they're teenagers or
or early 20s or whatever i mean where
does that leave you in
in in considering how safe they are just
going out going to see friends going to
the pub i mean what what concerns you as
i i've got as a as a human being
being in there i'm the proud father of
uh four children and that's uh includes
three girls including two teenage
girls and and you know i think as as any
parent in the country uh that
over the last few days especially uh
after this uh verdict i think we would
have all thought about our own families
and what needs to be done but i think
i'm just with every other parent in the
country
you know thankful
for our police in the work that they do
to keep us safe including my daughters
and everyone else but also
asking about the the reforms uh the
police can make and asking them to show
the leadership that is necessary to make
those reforms and and i think they will
be coming forward with reforms but
working with the government i think we
can learn from this and make things
better
minister it's good to talk to you thank
thank you very much thank you
okay let's have a quick whip through the
papers with badisha and dornissa morning
ladies look uh can we kick off badisha
with the mirror please looking at the
fuel crisis
yes uh after that excellent well
grilling of sanjay javid who is very
defensive we now have some scary
headlines about christmas being
cancelled the uk is over uh this is
about the fuel crisis it's about what
you've been talking about all morning
which is the army driving tankers of
actual petrol towards service stations
it's the looming tory party conference
starts on wednesday it's also the
looming possible covet inquiry around
christmas and new year don't think
anyone would be surprised if that
happened and it's about all the pressure
on the pm so
not just the entire country but the pm
himself boris johnson has been caught
short there's a huge amount of
questioning surrounding how we're going
to get out of this how did we get here
exactly as you said yes it's covered yes
it's brexit yes it's rising fuel prices
yes it is uh the ending of furlough
relief the pressure on jobs the way that
so many of us have not made a big rush
back to socializing or to the office or
to
central parts of town so it is a kind of
uh it's an honest horribilist i think
for
boris johnson and i love that the daily
mailers at daily mirror is leaning into
that pulley and just saying you know
what let's just put our heads under the
duvet and i'll see you again in
springtime
sounds like a pretty good plan to me uh
let's look at the times dawn um concerns
over what some universities are doing
yeah this is an interesting one i
thought we changed we changed the pace a
bit today with this one um universities
have accused of um advising uh abusing
powell with some of the
introduction modules that they're giving
to children
in particular the times have picked out
some andrews university i think which is
one of the top three universities in the
country and evidently children have
youngsters they're 18 obviously and
we've got record numbers of 18 year olds
going to university this year steven and
some of them might even get to have
face-to-face lectures a lot of
universities still charging the full
amount not doing that anyway this story
is about the introduction module for 18
years going there and they are handed a
questionnaire that says you have to
acknowledge your personal guilt is a
useful point in overcoming unconscious
bias and if they disagree with this they
found the module and it's like
where are we going with this and why are
we piling you know unnecessary guilt of
18 year olds who have been let's face it
through so much in the pandemic 18
months of disrupted lessons and exams
and everything and now they're going to
university which should be the best
years of their life and we're piling
guilt on them because they have
unconscious bias i mean what what what
are they guilty about being maybe
slightly well off and going to
university their background their skin
color can we just stop in universities
just start teaching kids face to face
preferably
yeah i think that's it's a very that is
a very odd approach i have to say um can
we have a look at the daily mail bedisha
and gp appointments
um we may have to double up or even more
oh not just double up times it by 12. if
you ever had one of those anxiety dreams
where you're talking about your shingles
or your piles in front of an entire
group of strangers then you're butt
naked from the waist down
guess what
it could be a reality because they're
now broaching the possibility that
instead of seeing your lovely gp
one-on-one who you've known since you
were seven years old and knows all your
stuff you could dial in for some group
zoom
face chat you and 11 other strangers
with your gp talking about all your
stuff and perhaps even having a you have
no authority here jackie weaver moment
if there's one particularly bullish pile
sufferer who wants to over talk on the
zoom see dawn doesn't like it i don't
like it either i wonder i wouldn't want
to show a group of strangers my rash
doll i don't know about you
i don't want to see your ratio either
thank you very much it's insane
and how many people have we put off even
more trying to access their gps already
we've got a huge problem with people
simply not bothering anymore and this is
absolutely insane
just can we just get gps open seeing
people i mean it's not it's not i'm i'm
sure this can't be a thing it cannot be
a thing
um dawn let's have a quick look at some
cheap holidays can we sounds good yeah
let's have some good news stephen shall
we this is the front page of dirty
express rock bottom this is not
referring to your rash by the way i'm
not actually going to just let you know
i haven't got it right
rock bottom prices spark holiday
stampede um obviously the the test for
double rm for vaccines and on monday so
there are lots of bargain holidays out
there this one mentioned is to tell a
reef where it's like 260 quid a person
um
we're all booking to escape the british
winter going somewhere hot and sunny and
it's cheaper than it's ever been
evidently so bye